okay Thank You Pete thanks so much for
having me here in Singapore and it's
very exciting it's actually my second
visit here beautiful city alright so I
think we answered the most important
question
who knows presto so I will just skip
through half of my slides and get the
gist right but the way we think about
Presta is maybe a little bit more unique
many people who use presto they just
query data is either in HDFS or as free
or some other object store but in
reality Presta is actually capable of
running queries across many data sources
at the same time and we see increasingly
more complex environments among our
customers where the data is not in one
place unfortunately right would be very
easy to have data all data in HDFS or as
free or other objects or like a drew
blob storage for example right but it's
not the case most of the enterprise have
data spread out across many databases
many storage engines no sequel engines
and to get insights from all of them
real-time whenever they want they need
sequel excuse statements across many of
those data sources at the same time so
it's more complacent that the list of
data sources you can access with Presta
is growing basically every month the new
connectors so some of the most recently
added by the community or Apache kudu
and elasticsearch and as you can see
that the do is is pretty extensive
already and for users
they actually leverage anything they can
do you know leverage BI tools they can
leverage sequel editors they can
leverage notebooks you know power bi
very popular among Microsoft's users so
it's pretty much anything as long as you
can speak sequel a brief recap of
Prester history some of you may know it
was born at Facebook about seven years
ago they first
into this issue of you know lots of
different data sources lots of data
obviously at that time it was a petabyte
now is exabyte right just you cannot run
effectively that's equal using
commercial solutions it's just
impossible to do it in a cost-effective
manner
so the the road Prester as a successor
to hive hive was already there it was
great was handling scale just wasn't
interactive and it wasn't able to access
many data sources at the same time so
now the open source of solution my team
that at that point was basically who
were running a commercial sequel on
hadoop solution we you our company got
acquired by teradata which is very very
well known in data warehousing she they
hit 40 years recently I spent three
years there in that time my team got
involved in open source project presto
so we till date we contributed about
half of the code to the project we made
many many releases along with engineers
from Facebook and then quite recently we
actually after data and form another
startup because we're seeing so much
potential for presto both in the cloud
and in on-premise enterprise
environments but we decided to do it
again as a start-up on and and then
quite recently some of the key engineers
founders of the pressor project and it
used to be at Facebook they actually
left Facebook and they just start an
independent software function to make
press to really independent of any
organization and make it more accessible
to the community so that that's that's
how it press the software foundation was
started earlier this year
all right so many of you use presto and
you may actually see your company logos
on the slide and if if you don't see
that let me know we can add that into
this list first is just everywhere
really and many many different
industries both cloud on-premise virtual
environments
all over the place some of the companies
here you may be local right so grab for
example and a few others it's just
amazing how quickly this adoption
happened and it was fascinating it was
you know a few years ago when we started
contributing to presto that community
was maybe a handful companies now it's
just growing really fast
and I think the cloud is really the
driver here so lots of those users are
in a cloud in the US but also Azure and
most recently also Google cloud so I
always want to review how people push
press up to their limits right as you
can see some of the biggest
organizations in the world running Big
Data they're approaching scale of
thousands of nodes with presto single
node clusters are nine hundred to a
thousand nodes you know uber Twitter
Facebook of Italy
they're running huge environments
there's almost 15 50% split of
on-premise deployments versus cloud
deployments some of those users are
making migrations from baked on premise
clusters to the cloud like Twitter for
example
Bagon promote additional customer moving
now to Google cloud and many other
organizations are making those those
bets
what fascinating about presto it can run
in both cloud and on-premise it can also
be hybrid right you mean you may have a
data source is located in one place and
run your computer somewhere else
because of separation from peers and
storage that's very easy to achieve
it's pretty amazing setup so let me know
if you think you have bigger data or
more nodes as those guys we happy to all
these my stats as well um all right I
think it's crucial to understand why
presto is gaining popularity like what
happened what's unique about pressed
that that is gaining this adoption right
now I think there are several factors to
this first obviously is a community
driven open
this project was it's used by a lot of
organizations that contribute back to
this they test this at scale they
contribute patches and features there's
no one vendor company that's driving
adoption of this which is really healthy
for the community the second thing you
know there's never something like enough
performance for your sequel engine your
data is growing every day
right you'll be running more complex
analysis so having something that's
proven scale and and it's fast is just
super super beneficial so that's a big
driver as well the third one which which
I touched on separation of computing
storage right up until maybe five years
ago you'll be running your big hive jobs
on your big Hadoop clusters you will be
collocating your compute with storage
right even those do even though those
the software was separate it was running
on the same machine those leveraging
locality the assumption was the network
is slow slow storage is slow you need to
bring computation to the data and look
now right everyone is actually
separating this it's moving data into
object storage in a cloud that's
abstraction like we are not actually
managing those machines anymore
right we're just so very cost
efficiently a loss of data and now we
just want to split up compute machines
whether those instances on a guru or us
or on-premise maybe kubernetes or VM
clusters those are they never actually
have storage on them I just do compute
right and first because it was just
design for that approach without maybe
maybe I was a conscious decision but
maybe if the founders of the party
didn't fully realize that but now it's a
big it's a big advantage and professor
you just right fit for the new cloud
environment model whether that's public
cloud or private cloud it saves you from
doing a lot of expensive ETL from your
data sources
to a big data warehouse or a big data
like you can actually query your Oracle
or sequel server or or IBM db2 you can
query all of them right now and join
with the data in your Hadoop or cloud
without moving the data physically
through the ETL process that you have to
define weeks in advance it's very
powerful and paradigm and then finally
no vendor lock-in so what I mean by this
there's you're not tied to your Hadoop
distribution to ship you the latest
version of hive spark or Impala or what
have you
you're not tied to a storage vendor
anymore because you can move your data
from one storage engine to the other and
presto will be still able to query that
so gives you freedom to architect your
beta platform and then you're not tied
to any particular cloud vendor because
as we know pressed around seen in every
single cloud and also on-premise right
that helps you a lot with designing
architecture that will survive how we
years of transformations and an
innovation in others in another sort of
storage or compute frameworks so
obviously super fast and I see sequel
beyond an SI sequel you can leverage a
ton of different sequel functions some
of the things I'd like to highlight is
you can run a very complex trigger
expressions that's super helpful to
analyze log data you don't need to log
in you need to put your log data into
specialized logging analysis framework
you can actually on sequel leveraging
those functions you can simplify your
sequel especially complex
transformations with with lambda
functions and expressions to save you
writing super complex nested queries and
you can also do really fancy geospatial
analytics which is something that was
first interviewed in contributed by uber
and now recently it's probably leveraged
by every single ride-sharing companies
in the world was a lot of food delivery
companies this
want to do analytics with with the zero
geospatial information in mind so I'm
lifting some of the examples here who
probably won't have time to go over them
right now but I think it's super
powerful that sequel is still at the
answer for many of the complex analytics
probably not as complex as as many
previous colleague was talking about but
there's a lot you can do with sequel I'm
still alright so beyond that you know
like presto it's open source project
there's the tendency to use open source
everywhere right so some of the popular
movement we see is around BI tools
reader superset Jupiter notebook are
really gaining popularity among sequel
users as well but you can still use
traditional dvb-c ODBC drivers for your
tableau QlikView power bi and also line
language bindings and extensions to to
make press the more powerful you can
contribute your own custom videos and
aggregate functions and also you can
actually build your own connectors right
if there's no existing connector for
your data platform you can actually
build your own or hire someone to build
theirs there's a Java API you can follow
to build a new connector and we see that
actually happening so just in the last
couple of years there's a bunch of
startups and companies building new
storage engines so specialized for
unique types of analytics and all of
those people are picking Prester as one
of the leading sequel engines to
integrate with so starting with with
data bricks and they expose an API to
allow to query the data like which is
stuff I can't figure this is an
optimized park' based table format
that's working great in a cloud there is
pulsar which is a party project for
streaming analytics iceberg is another
cloud oriented storage engine for
for four large tables hibachi hoodie and
that's coming from uber and to two
things from tile DB and you get by DB
with of startups building specialized
search engines and there's also internal
projects like a grab they built a sequel
access for for database storing their
metrics with Dakota area DB you can read
more about it as well so it's pretty
powerful and mechanism so just just a
very quick introduction about me and my
company so I mentioned we are involved
in the project for over four years we've
done lots of contributions to press so
we offer a freely available distribution
of Presta we can call it you know we
might be a club there a forester or
something like this you can grab it for
free and run anywhere we support
customers on the premises but also in a
cloud most recently introduced a
kubernetes integration that allows
pressed to run in in Azure in Google
Cloud and enable us and also on premise
right kubernetes is everywhere and
allows you to standardize on one payment
model with auto scaling h.a you know
like making things very flexible and
compatible with all the environments
some of the things we contributed back
to the community as an open-source we
we've done lots of extensions to answer
sequencers to make you know we're really
compatible with BI tools and complex
analytics we've done a lot of
performance improvements also security
integrations you know like in the early
days per service was great acquiring
massive data but it wasn't compatible
Kerberos held up things like Rangers and
free and so on so we fix up gap and then
work on spill to disk and cost-based
optimizer and cosmos optimizes I think
they would like to focus really and this
talk to show how you know applying some
of the performance optimizations now
from data base industries known for
decades are improving
research today and improving and cost
efficiency of rain needles and
environments so personal itself was
built for performance from the beginning
right that was the motivation why Presta
was born as a successor to hive at
Facebook super fast : our execution and
vectorized operations efficient
structures internally pipe and execution
really good very good architecture from
the beginning
right but was lacking cosby's optimizer
so so my team just going back to two to
maybe eight years ago we sort of started
building those technologies in my
previous startup and then when we
started contributing to presto four
years ago our goal was to always to
introduce those two presto and make that
impact to the open source community
so we've embarked on this work we
decided to do very basic optimizations
first and see how far they can carry us
so we leveraged statistics that you only
collect in your hive meta store for your
Hadoop environment or for in a cloud
environment you know hybrid also is the
standard for metadata and in the Big
Data environment and they tell like so
we we leverage those to do three things
really join reordering join type
selection and also this is decision
which join us on their left or versus
right side and you know there is a big
big blog post probably several of them
discussing the details but in a nutshell
you know we leverage the basic stats
from meta store like number of rows
distinct number of distinct values in a
column and so on we we leverage that you
estimate how expensive is to run
analytics taking into account CPU memory
and network i/o and we are doing those
basic optimizations by switching you
know typically in your query really like
you have many joints right there is
nowhere you know the perfect joint order
yourself we there's no way you know
which one of them should be distributed
versus broadcasted but we've starts
first row is able to make automatically
this
season to do that very well so we'll be
doing so the the joint selection will be
doing the decision among two tables
which Sun should we be on you inner side
which is outer side doing this properly
saves CPU time and memory and just
improves performance in general and then
for more complex in of our sequel
statements where you may be filter data
you have four conditions that will
change the game right you cannot just
look at the table size anymore
you have to look and how selective so
the filters are how much you're going to
reduce the effective number of rows
you'll be looking at the joint
cardinality trying to estimate how many
rows will be produced by your join all
of this is very complex algorithm and
will basically produce something that
presto believes is of the optimal joint
order given the statistics and things we
have estimated Town we handle left deep
join trees and bushes so really
exploring all all possibilities to
already perform very well and just to
give you a sense where this leads us
right so first up before optimizer was
already very fast but was just breaking
for the complex queries now we leverage
TPC D s benchmark which is pretty common
in the industry to measure sort of how
super engineer's is running effectively
and we run all the 99 queries among
those I'm just highlighting maybe 20 of
them that are just benefiting greatly
form optimizer right so this is a simple
fact that press is choosing the right
join order or the joint strategy it will
lead you to speed ups you know from like
5 X 10 X to even 20 X right and if you
think about this this is this is now a
deal breaker right because now you can
run more queries effectively you can
make your users happy because they just
get answers quick quickly and you are
able to push
- to do bigger jobs and if you take the
same thing and run it in a cloud which
is the environment you probably mostly
working with that's now translating
trust and translating directly into
savings right which because you can run
fewer machines in a cloud pay less for
compute or just take more workload and
be able to deliver more business results
to your users right so simple benchmark
we ran and with an optimized pressed on
EMR versus the one with optimizer first
of all half of the queries that were
failing before are now going to execute
successfully which is with a big deal
and the second thing among those that
are successful we are seeing speed-up in
offer for example here you can see half
of the course are 5 to 10x faster right
and some of them are in a more than 10x
faster and and and it's just like really
really improving user experience so
which is most recently in our team
delivered all that probably around like
April last year I contributed back to
the community over the next several
months but we are not stopping there
right we want to push this even further
what makes personal unique is that now
we can leverage presto for running
complex analytics across many different
data sources and leverage optimize the
optimizer to to go beyond just big data
stored in Hadoop platform or or in a
cloud right we can do enable DBS and
DBMS Federation right so if you are
joining or queries against Big Data and
your traditional relational databases
now optimizer is taking into account
stats from both environments and coming
up with the plan that's optimal in
across those two different data sources
we can leverage additional catalogs we
can actually employs personal stats
directly rather than leveraging high for
that and just overall
sort of optimizations in selectivity and
cardinality estimations you know I would
say we have still plenty of work to do
to improve it you know first of all we
discover various limitations in
statistics in a hive metal store we
would like to fix how estimates are done
for partitions most of your workloads
are only picking several partitions from
your big data source
today hive is very primitive in the way
it supports sort of aggregate statistics
so what I like to improve that we would
like to introduce statistics for more
connectors to provide you even better
experience in those sequel on anything
environments and tolerate missing and
incomplete stats it's a big deal like in
some of those environments you may not
have stats for all your tables or all
partitions right we want to improve that
by by sort of applying some heuristics
to allow you to leverage whatever you
have already collected and and then sort
of making some some reasonable guesses
about the situations that are not fully
analyzed and then we can go further in
terms of estimating more operators for
values data based operations we can
adjust cost model to your hardware so we
quickly realize that some of the tuning
options are really unique to
environments you'll be running right so
your own premise Hardware may have
different performance characteristics
versus your cloud environment right for
example in the cloud often you may have
less CPU cores but you're you know like
the network may be slower your hire this
guy own and it's a bit more limited
versus your highly optimized and
on-premise environments so there might
be some different approaches there and
also adaptive optimizations it's
especially with the clouds your cluster
may actually expand and shrink based on
how much artists you throw at this
knowing house variables change may Imay
improve
your core performance or actually
decrease the quit performance so making
adaptive optimizations while the crew is
running especially for larger drops is
really important um and then this whole
concept of trades were you may track
interesting properties of your CUDA plan
that may not directly be expressible as
a less-expensive plan but it's very
valuable to narrow your that I sorted in
a certain stage of your operation before
you push to the further stage and we
also want to involve connectors in in
optimization so so far Preston has a
global optimizer
and it treats every single data source
and connector as a relatively dumb data
store in a sense providing rows and
columns it cannot do a gregarious joint
or anything like that so in the in
earlier this year at strata data
conference in San Francisco Martina and
I were talking about that how we can
sort of figure out what to push down to
your data sources are more capable than
just objects store or HDFS so we'll be
exploring this and probably coming up
with some designs later this year so
that's that's about it I always
encourage people to run their own
benchmarks on their data and see how
pressure performs but if you just want
to look up what other people did in the
past is there's a bunch of links
obviously those slides would be shared
so you can click of them and see what
people are doing how they finding
redshift not being super fast anymore
and definitely less cost effective and
there are comparing commercial solutions
to open source solutions SPARC and other
things definitely go ahead and take a
look and yeah that's about it
I highly encourage you to come read our
blog and sign up for a newsletter to be
more immersed in the Presta community
contribute to the project talk to me
right now the coffee break office hours
if you have any use cases and just want
to learn more about questa we have a
bunch of contributors to the project and
commuters and we'll
to encourage you to join the community
as well thanks so much
[Applause]
any questions for Carmel here I got it
anyone questions yep
so I'd like to ask what are deploying
common deployment pylons that you see
for presto like for example is it's
common more common for companies to kind
of have of one super big cluster that we
shared among many users or you know so
what are the parents there and I mean
what use keys thank you yeah I'm so
deserving so the question is about what
are the deployment strategy big class
services a number of small clusters I
think it depends really especially with
the cloud or cloud light deployments say
kubernetes we're seeing more push
towards smaller clusters some of them
will be temporarily also scaling to a
big cluster some of them will be
shrinking back some of them will be shut
down if you have cloud or cloud like
environment I would be going rather I'll
be advising you to try dynamic approach
group users definitely do not run a
single customer user right but if you
have a department that's doing some
financial analysis or ad analysis like
group them into several clusters and
manage their work profile that way and
and if you have a bunch of users that
are using fast bi analytics put them
aside from those running big discovery
ad hoc jobs that may be just more
resource intense and they have different
SLA profile and you just don't want to
mix the two because we poor experience
for both else
all right so common we'll be in office
hours in half an hour after our break so
thank you camel